build it draw it play it Vsauce this is
your home for some of the greatest
creations from everyday people
this is B deep and building Tomohiro
Inaba creates sculptures using steel
wire check out his website for 8 years
of amazing creations jeremy Mayer's
typewriter assemblages are sculptural
creations made from typewriter parts he
doesn't use any glue or welds he simply
takes apart typewriters and reassembles
them like this make magazine shows us
how to make a form fitting case or
drawer liner using an old t-shirt and
some canned foam and Tom Manuel's
steampunk masks and helmets are made of
leather and resin he has a ton of
incredible designs and even some how-to
tutorials on his blog drawn if you have
a tree that needs painting ask Curtis
killer he paints dead trees and installs
them on private landscapes as a natural
form of art while michigan artist eric
day uses pushpins to create portraits he
takes a photograph of the subject and
processes it into the five colors that
pushpins come in and uses up to 11
thousand of them for one portrait now
let's look at some criterion style SNES
game covers
finally mike mitchell made some bloody
old-school videogame characters for the
super IM 8-bit show in los angeles
playin whiskey shivers created this
one-man band human centipede video
Gregg Pattillo is the beatboxing flute
player here's a Power Rangers theme song
meadow cover
and finally Nathan Barnett up Keith
AdvoCare II Fame created this dancing
music video
come on
we're not done yet
submit your own BD piece to facebook.com
slash Vsauce gaming and as always thanks
for watching